Alright, with just a couple more definitions we'll be able
to nail down what PAC Learning is. So let's consider a,
concept class C. That is to say that the set
from which the concept that we're trying to learn comes from.
L is our learner. H is the hypothesis space, so
it's the set of, of mappings that the learner is going to
consider. N is going to be the size of that space.
So kind of the space of the hypotheses that are being considered.
D is that distribution of inputs like we looked at
before. Then we got Greek letters epsilon and delta, where epsilon
is our error goal. Which is to say we would
like the error in the hypothesis that we. Produce to be
no bigger than epsilon. It could be smaller, that'd be
great. It could be zero, that'd be awesome. But it can't
be bigger than epsilon. But, we could get really unlucky and
actually not meet our error goal. And so delta is what
allows us to set a, a kind of uncertainty goal or certainty goal, which
is to say, that with probability one minus delta, the algorithm has to work.
>> And by work, you mean has to. Be able
to produce a true error, less than or equal to epsilon.
>> Exactly.
>> So why can't we always force epsilon to
be zero, and, you know, delta to be zero?
>> Right, to be absolutely sure that we get zero
error. So the, part of it is because we are sampling
training examples from this distribution D. and it's always
possible that we, for example, unless well, as long as
there's probability mass on more than one example, there's always
a probability that we draw a fine sample that only
ever gives up one example over and over again. That's
fair. So we just have to be really careful about
that. So, so if we're that unlucky it's very unlikely
to happen but when that happens our error is going to
be very high. But that's okay because it won't happen very often.
>> Okay sure,sure. So basically you can't force it
to be zero under all circumstances either epsilon or
delta you can't force them to be zero under
all circumstances. So you have to allow somewhere to. Exactly,
it gives us the wiggle room we need. Thats
actually where this name PAC comes from. It stands
for probably appoximatly correct. I see. So we would
like to be correct, but then we are just going
to keep adding weasel words until we can actually achieve it.
We would like to be correct, but we cant be exactly
correct, so let's be approxiiamtly correct. But we can't be approximately
correct all the time, so let's only probably be approximately correct.
>> So using your, your, your words here you
could have called that one minus delta epsilon correct.
>> Yes, right. That's exactly right. That's what the Greek
letters are playing, and correct is the, this you know,
error Sub D of H equals 0.
>> Yeah, so 1 9 is delta upsilon error sub D of H
equals 0 doesn't roll off the tongue
quite as well as probably approximately correct.
>> I would agree with that.
>> Okay fair enough.